Apple's been fighting the European Union
for the last couple of years as the EU
has been trying to force them to become
more user and environment friendly and
they are winning but don't worry apple
has a trick up their sleeves to make
everyone happy well not everyone just
the residents of the EU and apple
themselves let me explain this Story
begins with a funny headline from nine
to five mac Apple hasn't even switched
the iPhone to USBC and the EU is already
complaining which is hilarious and some
more context right here from Mac Rumors
the EU is warning Apple about limiting
the speed of uncertified USBC cables for
iPhones and if you don't know what the
heck that means let me explain basically
a couple of years ago the EU was working
on a law that would make USBC mandatory
for phones sold in the EU by the fall of
2000 and and 24 and then in October they
gave the final approval for a law that
would force iPhones to switch to USBC
and that law basically means that if
Apple wants to continue selling iPhones
in the EU which they definitely do for
profits then they have to switch the
iPhone from lightning to USB type-c and
then of course in October of 2022 Apple
themselves confirmed that the iPhone
will follow the new USBC law and then a
couple of months ago the leaker unknowns
21 confirmed that apple is switching to
USBC one year early with the iPhone 15
lineup that's coming later this year so
yes it looks like the EU lawmakers won
beating Apple in this case and the whole
point of the whole law from the very
beginning was to allow EU residents to
switch to Simply using one cable for all
devices instead of having to have both
lightning and USBC and that change would
of course reduce waste the only problem
for apple is that they currently sell a
lot of lightning cables including
third-party cables with mf5
certification so this law would end up
screwing Apple because a lot of people
already have pre-existing Chargers and
cables that they could just use to
charge their iPhone so Apple came up
with a master plan just a couple of
months ago news broke that Apple was
actually planning to limit the iPhone
15's usb-c port in the same way as
Lightning so basically adding mfi
certification to the actual USBC Port
itself and then we later got even more
detail saying that your iPhone's USBC
charging speed would actually be limited
if you're using a non-apple mfi cable so
if you use your old USBC cable that you
had laying around you would have limited
charging speed and that came directly
from shrimp Apple Pro who actually
leaked the new Dynamic Island design
with the Dual hole punch cutouts and he
even went as far as to say that cables
with no mfi will be software Limited in
charging speed and data so your actual
data transfers will be slowed down
artificially even though the actual
cable supports it but because it's not
an apple mfi cable which is hilarious
and then a month after that Misha quo a
very reliable Apple leaker also agreed
saying that USBC would enable faster
charging speeds for iPhone 15 which is
awesome but only with the certified USBC
mfi cables so apple is trying to
basically play around the whole USBC
situation and even worse just last week
we have had some breaking news from the
leaker Tech Reeves saying that Apple has
already begun mass production of USBC
cables with mfi certification they're
already on it but not only that they're
releasing mfi wired earpods the earpods
that we had years ago with a lightning
Port will now be coming again with a
USBC Port but with mfi certification so
apple is already rolling this out ahead
of September with the iPhone 15 launch
the only problem is that apparently the
EU Regulators are watching Apple leak
videos and tracking Apple leaks because
they saw that they're doing this mfi
limitation and they're literally warning
them saying that if Apple limits the
USBC Port they won't even allow iPhones
to be sold in the EU so basically apple
is getting screwed making things even
worse for apple back in March Ming shiko
estimated that these new USBC iPhone mfi
requirements would boost Apple USBC
charging brick shipments because if
Apple requires you to have their own
charging brick to unlock the faster
charging speeds then they would
obviously sell a lot more because you
wouldn't want to buy some other
third-party brick if it's limited so
this basically shows that Apple doesn't
really care about the environment that
much they care more about their profits
because they're going to try to force
you to buy another USBC brick instead of
using your pre-existing old third-party
brick from somewhere else and then of
course you're gonna have to buy a
matching mfi USBC cable from Apple to
get the best charging and transfer
speeds and the crazy thing is that
people would actually do it the Apple
leaker analyst 941 on Twitter basically
confirmed that the iPhone 15 in Pro
Models would get Thunderbolt 3 with
apple heavily invested into video
recording with special recording output
features and a focus on importing to
workstations or professional computers
like Max so basically if you want to
have blazing fast transfer speeds to
your Mac you're gonna have to use
Apple's mfi cable with Thunderbolt 3
support even better he also said that
there will be a special Thunderbolt 4
feature in iOS 17 but this is not going
to see the light of day until the iPhone
15 Pro gets released because it's
reserved to them so it's actually going
to support Thunderbolt 4 and apparently
there's new cinematography features
that'll allow live 4K Thunderbolt
outputs to monitors while recording of
course using a special Apple mfi
Thunderbolt cable so apple is basically
planning to put major marketing emphasis
on the new Thunderbolt support in the
iPhone 15 Pro Models which is insanely
fast compared to the current USB 2.0
speeds so that by itself is going to get
people to buy Apple's own cables if they
know it's going to unlock the faster
transfer speeds and or charging but the
EU is obviously having none of that
since they're already warning them even
though it's all based on leaks and
making things even worse for apple back
in 2022 the EU was trying to pass a new
law that would force side loading and
third-party app stores on the iPhone
under this new law which of course Apple
doesn't want to have because they're
going to lose their profits from the IOS
app store and of course because we know
that's Apple's bread and butter a huge
part of their services Revenue Apple
fought back and tried to detail and say
how side loading and third-party app
stores would undermine iPhone security
which of course it would because Apple
keeps a tight lock on the App Store
making sure there's no scams or issues
like that but of course they're also
protecting their own profits and in July
of 2022 the digital markets Act passed
which could force Apple to allow
competing app stores and more and guess
what happened in December Mark German
from Bloomberg confirmed that apple is
in fact planning to allow third-party
App Store alternatives on the iPhone for
the first time that is unbelievable
that's so hard to believe but don't
worry the folks over at Apple have a
trick up their sleeves just a couple of
weeks ago we got a report saying that
the iOS 17 side loading features would
not be coming to the US Mark gurman also
said that Apple May downplay the iOS 17
side loading to such a agree that it
might not even be mentioned at WWDC at
all so basically what if apple is
completely radio silent on this feature
they'll basically release it publicly
but they won't mention it at all not
even a simple mention of it coming out
and of course they're going to be trying
to avoid an uproar from other countries
which then might lead to other countries
trying to pass similar laws which apple
does not want at all they just want to
do the bare minimum to stick to the law
in the EU and then sweep the whole thing
under the rug and this right here is
Apple's master plan it was revealed just
last week that iOS 16 already has a new
hidden system to restrict specific
features based on the user's location
the new system internally is called
country D and it was silently added with
iOS 16.2 but is not not actively being
used for anything just yet but we know
what it's going to be used for this
system is basically going to allow Apple
to easily determine if the device is
being used in an EU country to allow
side loading so if you're anywhere else
in the world side loading will literally
be locked out and it won't work at all
but it actually gets worse than this
analyst 941 confirmed that apple is also
going to require an Apple ID that it was
set up in the EU and you must remain in
the EU with multiple stipulations that
are met in order for side loading apps
to continue working so they're going to
lock it down like crazy you're not going
to be able to just travel to the EU and
be like boom hey it works side loading
no you have to set up your Apple ID and
the EU confirm that it's there confirmed
by location in the system that you're
actually there for side loading to work
and that means you're not going to be
able to buy buy an EU iPhone and ship it
over here and have the feature work
apple is doing this in a very very smart
way to lock everything down and ensure
that they get their profits everywhere
else in the world you might be able to
have full speed charging with a
third-party cable because of the law but
in the US you would not have that so
basically the residents of the EU are
going to be very happy since they're
going to gain features that nobody else
can get and then of course Apple
themselves are going to be happy as well
because they're ensuring the maximum
amount of profits in the rest of the
world while still complying with local
country laws and that means they're
going to be able to sell their mfi USBC
cables and accessories throughout the
rest of the world with no problems
making more money so let me know what
you think about that down in the comment
section below if you enjoyed this video
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and see you in the next video
foreign